it's a fairly natural question if you're
looking at the sequence of prime numbers
say P whinings 2 P 2 s 3 and so on how
big do these gaps get and we know that
actually the gaps can get pretty big so
there's a very high school argument that
if you take numbers 1 x 2 x 3 up to z
times 100 and then you look at this
number plus 2 this is going to be a
multiple of 2 because these a multiple
of 2 and this first big number of
product of numbers between 1 and a
hundred is Markel t another way that
mathematicians might like this is 100
exclamation mark plus 2 so this is
multiplied all numbers up to 100
together and then add to but then
exactly the same argument means that 100
factorial plus 3 is going to be a
multiple of 3 and so implicit 100
factorial plus 2 can't be prime because
it's a multiple of 2 and it's bigger
than 200 factorial plus 3 can't be prime
because it's a multiple of 3 and bigger
than 3 and similarly you can go all the
way on to 100 factorial plus 100 and
this can't be applied because it's a
model of 100 and bigger than 100 and so
this is 99 consecutive numbers none of
which can be prime numbers and so you
know that there has to be this gap
between plant numbers of size at least
100 but obviously you can replace the
hunger here with any number you like and
that shows that there are arbitrarily
large gaps cream prime numbers it seems
to make you physically you've done
approach it you've proven that they were
right so this is completely a rigorous
mathematical proof that whatever number
you like taking a million take a billion
there exists a prime gap which is bigger
than a billion or bigger than a million
or bigger than a billion billion billion
or bigger than the number of atoms in
the universe and so there are these
really huge gap screen prime numbers but
the prime numbers where these gaps occur
and may be really huge themselves and
then there's this question those two
okay if I have a phone number of about a
million digit
how big can the gap stream prime numbers
be for example if you're trying to find
a prime number let's say I challenge you
to plan find a prime number that
subsides about a militant one way you
might try and go about it is take a
million try and test if it's prime if
it's not prime and millions not
time-tested million 110 million to 10
million three until you find a prime
number and this is actually we believe a
pretty good way of finding prime numbers
that it's completely deterministic you
can do it quite quickly on a computer
maybe takes you wild by hand when they
after the millions but a computer can do
this very quickly
however mathematically our theoretical
understanding of this is pretty poor at
the moment and it could be the case that
you have to go on ages and ages before
you find a prime number if there were
these really large gaps between prime
numbers so you want to make sure that
random dirty through at the number line
didn't happen to land in the middle of
an awesome prime gap exactly yeah so if
there was some awesome fine gap this
would completely screw up your attempt
to find prime number quickly by just
testing each number in turn and it might
take heat death of the universe before
your computer pub actually finds a prime
number which could be a pretty big
problem so mathematicians are very
interested in saying given Prime's of
about this size of size about a million
or about a billion how big can the prime
gaps be and in particular can we do
constructions that are maybe better than
this
factorial plus two Pat's or plus three
Pat constructions to try and understand
the large gap stream phone numbers so I
guess this is the large gaps between
Prime's problem when you ask him how
large kin gaps can be but it really
became famous because Paul Erdos very
much popularized this problem Paul Roche
was very charismatic mathematician he
used to put challenge prizes so he put
numerical bits of money on different
problems so he would say if you can
solve this problem that I don't know
itself I'll give you $50 here's a $20
problem here's a $100 problem and he
used to do this is a great way of
encouraging mathematics amongst the
community the largest amount of money he
put on any problem with $10,000
he put it on precisely this large gaps
between primes problem he didn't want
someone to completely solve all we could
possibly asked for about large ethical
things because that'd be too ambitious
however he and a few other
mathematicians led me Robert ranking and
their Cynthia had a method of doing
slightly better than this multiply all
the numbers up to 100 and then had to
add the advi-- but it was only slightly
better and somehow that's the only way
we knew of constructing what were really
larger than expected gap stream phone
numbers it was kind of frustrating for
math additions that we had this one way
of constructing large gaps between prime
numbers and we had no other ways that
did any better than Landon irishes
problem was just to try and do better
than what they'd done so independently
there were two different proofs of this
earnest challenge problem using rather
different techniques but both based on
similar ideas to the work they've been
done previously on consecutive days it
came out in consecutive days I worked on
this problem and also there's a
collaboration between PayPal Ben green
Kevin Ford and Serge I can Jurgen who
came up with a different way of getting
of submerges problem and getting larger
gap screen prime numbers so we knew
about each other but I was the slow one
they've got their heads one day ahead of
me we have this website where we put up
new papers and yeah they got in one day
ahead of me I was the second one
so there are different ideas so as I
said before to improve on what corrosion
his collaborators had done you really
needed to get some new automatic
understanding about the prime numbers in
my work it turned out that you could use
some new asthmatic understanding about
the prime numbers that was a
generalization of some of the ideas
they've been used to work on banner gap
screen times so somehow bizarrely if you
reinterpreted the whole ideas behind
small gap screen phone numbers they
could be useful to get a tiny
improvement in our knowledge about large
gaps between prime numbers if you took a
different understanding of the whole
thing where the other paper used ideas
based on Ben green and Terry towns
previous work on long a thematic
progression
in the primes quite famously 2005 Ben
green and Terry Tao
prove that you get arbitrarily long
automatic progressions in the time so if
you just take one time you can add a
constant amount add a constant man add a
compliment add a constant man and you
get these strings of prime numbers and
they showed you can if you choose those
starting time correctly and you choose
the difference correctly you can get
arbitrarily long strings of prime
numbers and again reinterpreted in a
rather different way they were able to
use this extra as making information
about the times in the proof of the
ideas of large gaps in prime numbers to
solve our - who's Chinese problem and be
better than what editions original
collaborators are done who gets the
10,000 bucks
ah so the 10,000 bucks it's slight
complicated I think as Ernest is
deceased but long Graham was in charge
of it and I think he's decided to split
it between the group of us what's the
new state of play what do we now know
about the gaps to claim so it's a
slightly technical statement but I'll
try and write it out for you so if you
look at primes less than X so I'm
thinking of X has been some huge number
like a billion or the number of atoms in
the universe then there is a gap of size
and now we have some big messy
expression involving lots of logarithms
so log x times log of log of x times log
of log of log of log of X divided by log
of log of log of x times some small
constant C if X is large and so this is
a slightly complicated and slightly
messy mathematical expression for if I'm
looking at primes of size X how big a
gap can I actively construct but this is
the current quantity it's some quantity
that gets bigger and bigger and bigger
as X gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and this is the current state of the arm
so if you want to try and beat our
I guess I think you need to come up with
some new aspect information and
understand about the times so the
challenge is to do better than this
function that's growing very slowly in X
but it turns out that that's completely
false that we really don't understand
these guys at all we really have the
most limited to ESCO understanding on
them and despite being the most
fundamental objects most of the most
simple questions that you could possibly
ask about prime numbers have been open
for thousands and thousands of years and
the most famous mathematicians are sort